you very much regretted that you didn't
get to direct you wanted to be the the
guy that directed most of the friends
episodes but you weren't able to commit
to that early on in the show you did the
pilot
and you did a number of those shows
you did 15 of them um
did you know right away when they got
that group together that i knew i knew
i i have
on all the sitcoms i do on all the
pilots i do i have a test audience
three days before we shoot the show i
have a single camera
and that helps me
um
if if there's a set that the whole
audience can't see
the single the camera will go down there
and just shoot a master so they always
can see it and uh
on that show it was through the roof
that's that single camera audience
they loved those characters
they loved them
and uh
uh you know i did the first i think
three or four and you know there's a
story about me taking the cast to vegas
because
i knew there was something special about
this show you know that happened on will
and grace that happened on cheers
the only show i that happened on it that
wasn't a success was a show called the
class
which was written by david crane and
jeffrey cleric david crane was one of
the writers on friends and one of the
geniuses
and that had a great uh audience but
it never made it but you can sense
in doing the shows whether the audience
reacts to it and uh
i knew then and there that how good that
show was and i also you know you talked
about casting before and how lucky you
are
uh i did that show was done in 94 and i
had
agreed to do four pilots already and
they sent me martin david sent me that
script and i said to my agent
wow i have to do this show it was in
fact 95 of the script that was sent to
me ended up on the air
so
i said i have to do it
so it was the last pilot i did in 1994
and those six people were available
so that'll tell you how lucky
you have to be yeah
you know jen had another show
that we were in second position she was
doing a show called muddling through on
cbs
which somehow they got her out of and
matt perry had done another pilot
and that pilot didn't go but those six
people and you think about if something
had been just a little different that
chemistry wouldn't have been there
and these are now iconic
tv characters uh
but you're right people don't realize
how much of
i mean i i think this occasionally when
you when you find out that humphrey
bogart was like the ninth choice to be
in casablanca you know
and
he was not thought of as he was not a
leading man and but
you know that's how it worked he was
available and a bunch of the other
people they wanted were not available
and so
that's how we get
you know humphrey bogart as rick and
casablanca and it's the same thing with
these television shows
it's uh
a million things have to go wrong for it
to go right yeah it was amazing that you
know
it's so i often you know people how how
did you find they think they think of
them now as stars and how did you get
them to agree to do friends
but they weren't they were you know
lisa was lisa was on the cheers
she was on a chair she played
an actor in woody and woody harrelson
was in a community theater and she was
the actress with woody
and so
uh you know it's just
you know they were unknown nobody knew
these people
and all of a sudden bang that's that's
the kind of show i like i like a show
where you bring a cast of people
nobody's ever seen before right
you know because then
the audience
feels like they've created a hit
by liking these people and they've
created stars so that's because you
bring these people you've never seen
them before so you have the sense of
surprise
when they oh my god that person's funny
you know with somebody like bill cosby
was real funny but you cut to cosby you
know something funny is going to come
out of his mouth when you cut to these
six on cheers you cut to the people on
on on on
on friends
yeah i'm sorry you cut six on friends
and you cut the people on cheers or taxi
you you have no history with them right
so will and grace i didn't know those
performers no so they opened their
mouths and oh my god i also think
there's something when the people
watching it have
it's the people that made them stars
right they weren't brought in as stars
so
you know we're saying no those people
are stars i like these guys
them they're it and that's that's much
more magical than oh yeah this person's
been around in show business for 30
years as a legend and now we're going to
give them their own show right right so
that's that's almost all the shows i've
i've ever done have
i i i i tend not to want to work
uh if if you got a star in the show
it just you know because
you have to serve the star and you know
it's just it throws off
stuff for me i like
the the unknowns and and having an
audience discover the unknowns
well
this has been a huge as i said i said at
the beginning
uh looking forward to this this is a
treat for me a huge treat
because i love your work i love
television you're so smart about comedy
um
and i do recommend people
this book is fantastic and you can read
this book if you're if you're in theater
read this book if you're interested in
television read this book if you're in
comedy writing read this book comedy
performing read this book it's just uh
uh and read it a different time for each
reason
yeah buy different copies um
no it really is and on a personal note
i'll tell you when i got started uh with
my late night show and was going through
a really difficult period and getting
written off all the time and constantly
reading that was going to be cancelled i
ended up i'd say about a year or two
into the show it was very early on and i
ran into you someplace
and you were very encouraging to me
and said some nice things to me and it
meant the world to me
it was a huge deal
and i remember thinking well if james
burrows thinks
i'm doing an okay job
then i think that i'm just going to live
off that for about a year uh or
or 30. uh so um thank you so much for
coming on the show and thank you for i
mean
i think you have provided me with maybe
uh 85 000 laughs in my life so
i appreciate it thank you for having me
yeah yeah this was great thank you thank
you
you